[Music]
oh
wow what recently you posted
a video using fleetwood
max song dreams do it do it give me the
cranberry juice
well give him the starbucks something
always happens always
happens when it's raining
play us always playing when they're
playing
and then he sings the last part yeah so
uh is this a tick-tock thing so this is
a tick-tock thing
is it tick-tock or instagram well he
posted on instagram after and then also
on twitter
what's his bad dog or whatever dog face
dog face
so he his name is nathan and
he's saying completely over i'll tell
you in a second i'll show you in a
second
so this is the video that went viral and
oh you know you know who i'm talking
about in there like you didn't know
this is nathan you know now no oh now
you'll know here we go
now you'll do another one
i love this it's fantastic here we go
wait for it
what's he on oh my god i feel like is
that vodka and cranberry juice
it's just cranberry juice just cranberry
juice
he didn't mix it with anything i feel
like he that that's a nice little
cocktail no it looks like just cranberry
juice it's just cranberry juice
but don't isn't that how you could drink
in public is you got a cranberry juice
and then you put some
you put vodka in it or something vodka
some scissors he's clearly
has done that but also was he on a
hoverboard no he was on a long board
oh okay yeah on a long board so here's
the back story
so nathan his backstory yes so nathan
he he started off on tick tock because
of
one of his daughters introduced him to
tick tock and then he was just like oh i
don't know what kind of content to put
and then the daughter was like you
should post up you
you dancing because he's such a goof and
he's always dancing
and so that's what he started doing and
then his video started
getting a lot of views but then when he
posted this one that this is the one
that really
got him mega viral and uh
and so that day that he filmed this
he was on his way to work and his car
he has like a really old car and it
actually just didn't turn on
so he had about 15 minutes left before
getting to work
and so he always leaves his longboard in
his trunk just in case his car
won't run and like this time it didn't
so then he
started writing as long where he had his
cranberry juice and because he says
that's his drink he love he loves that
drink
and so he ends up just he decided at
like there's like this
like this ramp near the freeway and
that's where he decided to
film this video as he was skateboarding
and
that [ __ ] just went viral so now at this
point though
everyone is discovering him and finding
out that
he's living out of an rv that doesn't
have any running water
and he's like plugged up to his
brother's house and so a lot of people
have been donating to him
up until at this point i think ten
thousand dollars he has now received
damn i'm gonna go viral damn this is
some wholesome news
yeah this is like a really dramatic
story i thought he was just
longboarding i thought he just i thought
he was just having a day drinking
longboarding yeah it's like whoa
that's i mean it's a great story it's
just that was so powerful
he was on his way to work he's like
everyone's like this is such a mood this
is
uh good vibes and all that stuff but
he's actually going to work he's
actually
what i was feeling it is a mood because
it's like no matter what you just don't
let [ __ ] get you down
because it's like your car broke down
and you're like [ __ ] it that's even more
meaningful
i think the best thing about it is that
he doesn't look like he's about to burst
into song
yes like he looks like he's too cool to
sing yeah oh you should watch his other
tech talks they're awesome he's nothing
but like all this wholesome [ __ ] i mean
i guess the one aspect of his content
that you wouldn't consider wholesome is
the fact that he's a big old
like weed smoker so his whole thing is
about like 420 and all that stuff
but isn't it funny though like your
daughter okay like she
she's like damn i work so hard to be a
tick tocker but dad comes in and does it
all
easy and wins what the [ __ ] and he's
done his life 4 28.
that will always be a thing though
watching like some dad like dancing
it's it's tails all this time dude
that's true
what's his handle uh well on instagram
is dogface208
he's now verified he's almost at a
million oh [ __ ] yeah
wow a lot of people i started following
him too he's now verified
well because as soon as you get
published and uh i've been trying to get
verified forever this
longboard is one time no has anyone made
a story
about you like like your name no dude
this is the part where bart comes on
he's like we didn't win so we don't get
enough stories you didn't have to do
that to yourself
okay guys i mean you didn't win i don't
get it oh yeah a backstory for steve
would you like to tell anthony no it's
it's really it's a
amazing story that we'll have to save
for off the camera the point is
um no no no like getting verified right
it's like all i get is those emails
that are just like they're yeah totally
fake misspelled
it's like russian i mean i i got
verified because
i had to talk to people that worked at
facebook and then
someone in the inside was able to help
me get it
because i i got denied why
they say that sometimes um it's the
algorithm it's like whatever criteria
there's just a lot of it helps if you
have media
like traditional media writing about you
that's how you see like journalists with
like 5 000 followers
that are um yeah blue check mark
because they they can write an article
about themselves or
their name is published journalists out
there hook it up me too me too
well i mean you guys were on tv it's
just your brand
the brand that you own brand is verified
that's why that's the thing is
is your brand can't be verified because
people know the kinjaz
but people don't know anthony hey man
they don't they don't know me man they
don't know anthony
they don't know me sorry i'm sweet i
have backstory
go ahead no sorry no it's about this guy
it's about this guy it is about this guy
sorry it's not about you
but you need to beat you to it so
nathan here because of his video going
viral he has actually
put fleetwood mac back on the charts he
did because of that
i just went oh man i was listening to
the chain
i was listening to dreams i was
listening to
gypsy something i was listening to
[Music]
what does that mean the rihanna no one's
the girl's name it's like rihanna
yeah but yeah so currently it sits at
number 29
what's the you can go yo oh
what's that one is it go your own way it
better be yeah
it better be huh but yeah dude so
uh to the point where fleetwood mac
ended up tweeting
oh they're like hey
thank you so much you brought us back to
life
nobody was listening to us that's not
true they always come back up like
randomly throughout time because of one
thing or another
i actually started listening to
fleetwood mac because of american horror
stories coven
uh season where like they were all
witches and then stevie nicks actually
cameoed in that season where she was
also a witch and all that stuff and i
didn't like you
by our own i didn't like him when she
did her own things oh
well stevie nicks alone you didn't like
it when she went solo no no
i don't know if she went solo but then
she has songs with just her name and i'm
like nah isn't that her going
no that is indeed her going solo
it's good to be back guys it's great to
be back
when did you guys discover the fleetwood
max like when did you hear it because i
heard it as a child
well yeah like i would hear it in
passing but i didn't actually like
gravitate towards it until i saw that
season
of american horror story and i was like
because they kept using their music
throughout the whole season
i was like oh my god i love it i never
watched the american horror story when i
listen to fleetwood mac
i feel like a jaded biker's wife that uh
is driving in the middle of the desert
because she's having a mid-life crisis
i can see that sounds like a good music
video yeah because it's
that era like all the people that grew
up during that time
they're probably around that age right
now or like they're
older yeah they're older so then yeah
them came out in 1977.
yeah so they're older than that it
really is timeless too because it's just
it's just wherever you play it it kind
of works for whatever's going on
especially dreams like
it's such a good song i like landslide
landslides it's got the feels
like which one's that one two slides
last slide
yeah yeah that one yeah i don't
recognize it yet
no it's okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
please
yeah cause we deal with that [ __ ] all
the time not like this guy
come on now sure come on now when you
win
how would you choreograph a fleet with
mag song oh yeah you would just be like
this the whole time
it would be somebody crying in the
camera i think especially for landslides
for sure that's a dramatic song or
you're just on a landslide while you're
like dancing you know what i mean
like so the word play is really dramatic
and then after that it's like slow
motion so slow motion works with
everything yeah
too literally something with cranberry
juice did you choreograph the dreams
i'd be like a biter then you know
joe a biter did ocean spray say anything
about this ocean
no actually nathan nathan got
interviewed by tmz and he was like dude
i'm waiting for ocean spray to hit me up
to do a commercial i'm so [ __ ] down
i'm just praying
this [ __ ] social media guys laying on
the switch over there it has to happen
he's falling asleep at the wheel over
there i'm sorry but i can't do the ocean
spray by itself i gotta dilute that [ __ ]
it's so strong man
i gotta go half water half ocean springs
with vodka
it makes my tongue dry like if you drink
it straight up
i don't know like the aftertaste it yeah
it's like tart
it's just gonna start a new thing where
people walking around with like a liter
of ocean spray
just
oh yeah it's a trend that becomes a
culture trend that'll be amazing
i i really like his whole his his like
his content that he releases is really
sweet it's really cute
yeah he's like dancing he's i don't know
it's just funny because he feels good
yeah it's so feel good because he's
he'll be at work and he's doing these
tick tock like lip singing stuff or like
he's dancing he's doing tick tock dances
too
like that you got it mom we'll subscribe
yes follow him this is me on the phone
with my mom and she just told me about
some new person and i'm like okay fine
[Laughter]
you're so fun steve you're so fun
but yeah so apple data found that this
song saw a 221
increase in streams with a 1
137 surge for shazam
app searches wow wow which is evidence
of virgin listeners
yeah they're they're discovering
fleetwood mac for the first time wow
yeah that's so cool it's like keep going
fleetwood mac
that's actually one of tick tock's
revenue streams apparently is is
the music so getting their people the
biggest people to use the music so that
it sells more albums and [ __ ]
[Music]
you